uh welcome everybody hello hello
i'm uh grandmaster mircha parley grass
and uh today i'm going to show you um
three of my uh of my end games
they are all played with the with the
black pieces
i didn't uh really wanted to
um to choose it like this but
this is how it turned out um so let's uh
let's see the first example is a game i
played
um in golden sense bulgaria
in 2012 with white
my opponent was kegel dmitry
the ending was about was about equal
here but
white maybe try to push a bit
push to push a bit too much and he
played h4 here
and um
this is where i want to ask you what
what was my reply how how did i meet
this
how did i meet this move
so you can you can write there in the
chat
i mean the the point is that now the
white king is
[Music]
stranded on g5 and
as difficult as it seems
i could i could get threats against
against the king
so what do you think
any any suggestions
okay so here
i um
uh first first of all i started with the
knight e7 well 97
allows maybe um
97 allows among others to
[Music]
to exchange this this knight and then
the ending should be should be about
equal
so it it doesn't uh it doesn't really
work
[Music]
so something has has to be done against
the king and the king is uh
well white king is stranded and uh my
opponent couldn't believe that
there could be threats against the king
but yes it's it's possible to to do
something
so yeah like most of the time everything
starts with the with the check
so here i just
i just played the
i gave the check h6 check now
white is forced to to the only square
king h5
yes yes exactly h6 king h5
but how about now
what uh what did i play now because
[Music]
it seems that my opponent had taken this
into account and then
he wants to go
[Music]
a g4 for example and
free up the position and
also if i move the if i move the knight
somewhere just
he for example night here let's say he
can just take the knight
and uh go here and i don't know i could
even be
be worse for losing this descending
so this is what he was this is what he
was counting on
but how did i proceed here
uh what uh
what did you play with with black
okay now that now the king is uh now the
king is in the corner
but um still
it doesn't seem like anything is uh
is going to happen uh well f4
f4 is just uh frees up the king i mean
um the king can then go to g4 obviously
he
he can take on f4 i don't know how
exactly
um anyway perhaps or
he could go even
he could try even let's say g4 and then
i could be in two zones here but also
for example
g takes f4 is is good enough
so now f4 doesn't doesn't work
um if i go
um if i go king f6 here for example he
can
uh he can just go g4
and then g5 so actually in this case
uh his uh his king on h5 is
quite useful
but there is a there is one more
one more possibility so waiting a bit
for the chat
knight e7 well 97 just takes the knight
and uh again king g6
and king f8 i have to go and this ending
can only be
be better for for white maybe it's even
winning
uh exactly knight h8 knight h8 was the
move
so sometimes the knight can is not
recommended to go with the knight in the
in the corner but sometimes uh sometimes
it's possible and it's good
like in this case so i i went to knight
h8
and now my question to you is what is
the plan of this move
the part that uh the h8 square is not
is not protected by by the
bishop on d6 so you mean g6 here well g6
uh
g6 you can just take on h6 and then
nothing happens i mean the king is happy
there
oh very good very good there there we go
so yes
um yes the plan the plan exactly the
plan is to go king
g8 king h7 and then g6 checkmate
yes exactly very good very good good
find
yes okay now my opponent realized
uh realized this plan but
uh there is not
there is not much he could do about it
for example in case of d5
okay i could i could just take one d5
and it's winning
but i might as well continue with my
plan
king g8 yes in the game he played
g4 indeed so here i can go king g8 and
uh already d take c6 and king h7
followed by g6
uh checkmate and if
bishop bishop f4 then
king h7 bishop h6 um
[Music]
yeah i just take the
i just take the the bishop with with the
winning position
[Music]
so yes indeed in the game he played
[Music]
he played g4 which which is quite the
first move
and now there is a
there is no time for something else i i
just have to continue with my plan
obviously one white wants to go
g5 and then even take one h6 or it
depends if i don't have the king one f7
to go g6
so let's continue the plan king g8
g5 he played king h7
well now the only um
yes exactly and now the only way to
[Music]
to avoid the mate is to
is to take on h6
and here i had two good
two good ways to to win the game
i chose i think the the more the more
spectacular one
um in the game i played
oh you mean g6 here okay g6 and knight
f7 was the the less spectacular way
yes everybody's saying g6 and knight f7
uh
looking for that fork yes this is
possible so
this is all forced okay taking on e6 yes
this uh this is winning
i mean knight c4 and then
king d5 for example and i have several
ways to win here like
uh night
knight to d2 or
just f4 with idea
92
[Music]
knight s3
so this um this was
uh this was a good way for example king
e4 here
king h6 king takes f4
king h5 uh kg 3
and now knight b6 the knight goes to
d5 and uh i'm going to win this one
yeah also here yes indeed 92
uh 92 f4 and then move like
b4 also also wins
yeah the idea is to maybe i can even
push b3 or um
it depends where he goes there i can
but basically after b3 i i can exchange
the spawns and then give the knight for
the
d4 pawn and then just win the
king's king's king and ending
but in the in the uh in the game i was
tempted
[Music]
to play something else
[Music]
so i went
uh i went knight f7 here
actually attacking both the bishop on d6
and threatening to go g6 checkmate
so there is only one way for him to
to go here he took on g7
now of course i took the the bishop
before it ran away
and now he had the
he had a nice trick i mean otherwise if
he doesn't do it i can just take on g7
with the winning ending um
very soon because i'm a i'm a pisa but
he played g8
queen chuck
i have to i have to take the queen and
then king g6 so now that
his king activated uh
very much and uh his threatens to
to go king f6 king e6 and
with enough counterplay for a draw
actually
but i had a i had a good reply
probably the only the only move here
and i'm waiting for you to
to help me win this well 98
98 is obvious indeed but
it's not so it's not so good because uh
it is passive so with such a passive
defense
defense the the game would be would be a
draw
uh probably he can he can push i know
f4 h5 h6 even here and
then just switch to the other side uh
yes yes exactly exactly
very good chat very good so the move is
94
actually and uh
this this is winning so 94 has uh
several ideas actually it uh
it doesn't allow white king to go to f6
uh it also threatens to go before knight
c3 and knight e2
so that has to be stopped somehow and
another point
is uh i want to play f4
again it's not possible to take one e4
and then 92 with knight f3
so very nice move and white uh
wasn't able to defend against all this
if a3 as i said f4 with knight d2 is
decisive so white went d5
but he gave up too much material already
so i took one i took on d5 king takes
f5 now knight is three
yes exactly then push push the pawns
yeah
very good uh king e5 uh
b4 knight king d2
and king a2 and
and white resigned so this was
uh uh
this was the first uh game
it was uh quite amazing that uh with the
so little material i was managed to
create a
mate net creating that
and now let's uh let's move on to the
next example
which is related to a blockade
very interesting game as well
[Music]
just a moment to set it up
there we have it so this is my
uh this is my game against uh
i was playing black against the tigran
cotanyan from armenia
uh it was 2008 in iroflot open in moscow
you're welcome so
this is towards the game it was a long
game
i was winning before but the game
continued on on and on
and now uh with the last move he played
the knight c3
uh here i had uh here i had an easy win
but i still had to to calculate the
variations and to be precise
so the win was okay
just to explain this ending uh my pawns
are quite advanced we have
opposite colored bishops and uh
probably white's only hope is to create
a blockade which could have happened in
the game
uh yes i flew with aeroflot airlines
and i can use the a pawn uh the far away
a pawn to
uh to tangle white's
uh pieces and then just to push on the
on the king side decisively with these
three points
well here here i made the
an inaccuracy or already it could be
called a mistake
and i defended my pawn on a4 which
seemed like the easiest way to win i
mean just
defend his pawn and then later on push
the pawns here
bring the king to
i don't know exactly where but let's say
like this
uh bring the king to to the queen side
yeah
then push the pawn further and win the
game without calculating so much
and i have to say that in these
situations it pays off to
take your time and calculate and just
win the game
right away but of course uh now i'm
saying this
when i'm not tired like i was in the
game also we are both tired and
we are getting short of time
[Music]
so here g4 g3 better
oh you're so eager to to push those
pawns
well g4 is uh actually a mistake here
because it allows white to go 92 and
already the position
is uh is a draw
yeah 92 and then then i have to push
this uh
this f pawn but um
it's uh it's just a draw i mean white
can play uh
yeah or if i push this y can play knight
and then
a4 one is a4 pawn is falling
so yeah that that was a trap i didn't i
didn't fall for it
uh the win was uh
something different for example i had
many many good ways to win
uh probably the easiest was to play
bishop f3
so as to avoid this uh this maneuver
with knight e2 no more
no more 92 and then
of course prepare to push the pawns and
it can be quite it can be quite decisive
for example there is no time to take on
a4
which is desirable but there is no time
for it because g4 then g3
h2 and it's
game over
so let's say white goes king h2 instead
then g4 again
and yes my idea now is to
is to play bishop g2 and then g3 with
the
with check very important and then of
course i can move the bishop away from
g2 and go h
h2 and win the game so for example white
again y doesn't have time for knight a4
because of
bishop g2 with g3 and h2 coming
so let's say he goes to move like
bishop c5 and then
i can go bishop g2 let's say
92 what else i mean
he has to he has to stop the pawn
somehow so he goes 92
and now
[Music]
now i can finally play g3 check
if he doesn't take on g3 then let's say
king there i can move the bishop away
even to f3 for example and then go h2
um maybe okay maybe there are better
squares like
b7 let's say in order to avoid knight d4
knight of three
but that that is also lost
so after g3 uh probably he has to take
on g3
takes king g3 and then
how about this ending
it's opposite colored bishops and i have
[Music]
a and h pawns
but
[Music]
yeah just yeah just bring the king to
to this pawn um
and yeah king e4 and it's completely
winning exactly
very good uh i will i'll give the a pawn
for the bishop on c5
so that will be a trade and then i'm
going to go back with the king and it's
winning because
this is the the right square it's a
light square so
on the same color as the bishop so this
was
this was easily winning
there were other moves that were winning
let's say king
king g4 was also winning or k6
k6 for example there is a
bishop h3 bishop c6 now now this works
and it is important
now my plan is to go actually king
king to e5 and it's important that
[Music]
i managed to drive away the bishop from
the d6 square
for example king h2 i can go g4
right now knight e2 king e5
and somehow white's pieces are lacking
coordination so i'm i'm winning this
ending
anyway let's go back let's go back to
the game
when i played bishop c6 the save move
keeping all my pawns and the position
must be winning right
this is uh this is what i was hoping
and my opponent played the
king h2
attacking my pawn and now it's very
difficult i mean
my idea i cannot even say my
my move was bad but it was uh it was a
mistake indeed
why did you play here as black
g4 exactly okay so i played g4 because
this was uh this was the plan
this was my plan to just push the pawns
but this is actually a mistake and it
misses the win um
the only way to to win here was to go
back with the bishop to g2
so going back it's probably the
yes yes exactly but this is probably one
of the most difficult
things in just to to admit that you just
made the mistake in the previous move
so yeah bishop bishop g2 was
was the right move so now king g1 i can
go bishop s3 and win as a
as i showed you before or for example
if knight e2 i could go
f3 knight g3 check
king e6 going towards the b3
bishop c5 yeah king d5 and uh
it's just winning note that this bishop
on g2 is very
good here because all the time i have
stress to go
f2 f1 for example if
the bishop is not controlling the
diagonal
and of course uh here
uh knight xa4 was impossible because of
g4 and
the variations like before yes bishop on
two pawns strong
pawn too strong yes um
but it was difficult to move to play
bishop
g2 and all the other moves are
are a draw like king e6 he can go bishop
c7
or even king g4 he can go
uh bishop e7 and it turns out i cannot
untangle my pieces now for example
bishop d7
just the waiting move he can go d1
um it is to go knight f2 of course
and if a3 there is no time to take the
the pawn right now so that would be
losing but
is just in time to go back knight c3
and then the knight is much more active
there
and he is threatening to to take the a3
on the next move
so for example f3 he can just go bishop
c5
bishop e6 um
king g1 a2 and
here we have a nice fortress king goes
to f2
and the bishop just stays on this
diagonal
and there is no way for me to make
progress although i'm three pawns up
but anyway let's uh let's go back to the
game
where i played g4
i mean the logical the logical move
and he goes uh very strong knight e2
i play the f3 of course uh modes like
knight d4 don't really help because of
king
here takes and now there is f2
with the f1 queen
so yes uh bishop g21
well there is no time for bishop for g2
because f4
pawn is falling so i have to go f3
[Music]
i go f3 he goes 93 check
logical and then i'm switching my king
to
sorry to the other side
so kinky six bishop f8
king d5
going over there
uh well i have to say that during the
game i was quite happy with my position
now
i was thinking okay there might be some
blockade there but
uh usually there are no there is no such
thing as
blockades so i'm just going to
to bring the king here push the pawn and
win the game
well things are not so easy
in the game my opponent played the king
knight h1 he played uh it's a strong
move
also king g1 was quite strong
king c4 king f2
king b3 and then knight f1 and we have a
blockade like
uh that we're going to
to talk a bit later this happened in the
game as well
so this uh this is a very good setup for
for white in this positions
um but he he reached that
same position the other way with knight
h1
king c4 knight f2
[Music]
uh bishop d7 of course i have to i have
to protect my
my guy on the on g4
and then king g3 the king activates
there but uh
there is no no threat with the king yes
bishop d7 i played
uh bishop f5 just to limit this
knight a little bit
91 king b3 there we go
i was quite happy here 93
also the knight is uh
is getting into position is getting to
f1 jumping there
bishop e6 again to to limit the
knight as you can notice the the g4 pawn
is not in danger if my
bishop is on this diagonal but the pawns
are quite blocked so
it's not easy to to make progress here
he played bishop d6
i pushed happily
and here he actually made uh
made a mistake but
i didn't i didn't take advantage of his
mistake
he played bishop f8
i mean he thought okay i can just wait
on this diagonal until the pawn
goes to a2 and once the pawn goes to it
then i can bring the bishop to g7
and control the long diagonal
which which makes sense
but there are better moves
so what he had to do actually here he
had to go either knight f1
and um get this blockade that we're
going to talk
later on about or play bishop
e5 um immediately
and then bishop c8 again
king king f2 with the with knight f1
coming and he's in time to
set up the blockade but in the game of
course there were many mistakes
and uh i only found
found out these mistakes once i analyzed
the game more
in in detail so
bishop bishop f8 and here
yes you you said right yes a2 was the
good move
so a2 was winning but uh
in the game i played king b2 which
seemed
to be tempting as well
so how how is the win after a2 bishop g7
and what do we do now
this is not this is not easy but i'm
waiting for your feedback
well there is no king c2
the knight is controlling that square
yes
so there has to be something else
i mean this uh this knight over here on
the bishop seems
uh seem to set up some kind of blockade
because my king is all these squares are
not
not available for my king
[Music]
but for example
uh if i um
if i mark the time with bishop d7
then there is time for knight f1 getting
into that fortress
but i have a h2 he just uh takes the
pawn
so h2 doesn't work just i'll just
take it but it's the other way around so
i could have i could play f2 very good
yeah f2 here was was very strong with
idea
bishop c4 and
here if it takes on f2 then i have h2
finally king g2 and g3
and now this is uh this is finally
meaning
i'll be able to to bring my bishop
to this diagonal
like this uh and
after f2 if he goes bishop e5
then i can play bishop c4 to force him
to do something then king f2
and then the the same story uh there is
no bishop h2 because of
a1 queen so king g2 and g3
and uh and it's winning
but let's go back to the game
so i played um king b2
i mean i wanted to to activate my king
first because
also so uh in this line
i thought okay he could have this this
blockade my king is not
he's not going anywhere i missed of
course i missed this idea
yes hardest part of the board yeah so
king b2 was
logical because i wanted to to break
this
this lockheed obviously and now
um now there comes another mistake
the way to go was to to play knight f1
reaching the blockade that we're going
to talk about
or even bishop g7 and knight f1
but in the game he goes for the check
he wanted to harass my king
then
[Music]
king to king c2 93
king d2 king f2
and here
here i missed the win how did i miss the
win guys
too many mistakes in this ending but
it's a very instructive
ending
yeah g3 g3 was g3 was the win
very good g3 was the win and a2 was my
move
okay a2 well for those of you who said
a2 it's a grandmaster move but it's a
mistake
so i was playing black i was playing
black here
so g3 king f3 a2
bishop there and g2 is uh is winning
i i'm going to play if king f2 just
g1 queen take take
and king all the way here
take and the wind pawn ending
unfortunately in the game
uh in the game i said okay there is no
difference i just go
a2 and yes in the game he
played bishop g7 blunder and
then i won bishop g7 then g3
because i saw it and yeah
he couldn't believe it king f3 g2
and king f2 g1 queen this was
this was the game note that there is no
knight g2 because of
bishop d5 or even h2
but as i promised you there was
this very nice blockade and here he had
an in-between move
namely knight f1 check
very strong and we finally reached that
blockade position that i i was telling
you about
um already for for some time so king c1
and now bishop g7 and it turns out
this is quite a or
king d3 but it doesn't make much of a
difference like bishop g7
and it turns out that there is no way to
make progress here
because all the time if i go king b1
then there is 92 check
and so i cannot um
i cannot promote my my pawn
on the other hand if i go bishop
bishop c4 then he plays
knight h2 and he attacks my pawn on g4
so the bishop has to go back and then
the knight goes back
and otherwise if i just mark the time
with the king let's say king c2
he can he has many
many moves with the bishop
yes i mean this this is unbelievable
because the pawns are so
close to promoting okay there are
opposite cards bishop
and this is this i think it's an amazing
blockade
and also it it doesn't work to bring the
king here because
he will uh he
will always have uh have checks so
for example if i bring
[Music]
just to show you if i go like this there
you go check
and then back and if i go
like this there we go check
so there is no
no way to make progress here and uh yeah
this this would have been a draw so this
is why i wanted to show you this
this example because it's uh it's an
amazing blockade
i i think yeah this is draw in the game
i won but
i was i was lucky and it was a game full
of mistakes
but i think it was quite instructive
despite the fact that we both we both
blundered but we were after a very long
game and we are short on time and
you know is the pressure
all right so let's see one final example
for today
let's move on to the next one
a very interesting game
my game against uh zoltan ribley
played in 2008 in bundesliga german
i bundesliga playing for the 3rd team
then
i was black
and
[Music]
ok this this is where we start we've
just exchanged the
on on e6 uh
bishop for for the knight and
this is actually a theoretical position
there
it comes from uh from maruti
with uh with black i was playing this
with black
uh the line where black takes uh
swaps the knight on the the knights on
d4 quickly
and then pushes a5 a4 in order to
gain space on the queen side so we can
notice here that white has the pair of
bishops
and the maruti grip
which give him some space advantage but
i have the
very strong dark square bishop the
knight on c5 is
is nicely placed and also i gain some
space on the
on the queen side by pushing the a pawn
so okay white is the move here he played
rook b1 which is a logical move
um if bishop takes e5
probably the best is to take with the d
pawn and then put the bishop to
d4 although it may not be so so much
so group d7 bishop b2 rook d1
king f7 to defend here and rook b7
probably slightly better for black but
it makes sense to just play
rook b1 and now
now i went king of seven he goes king f1
to to bring the king in the
in the center as well here he offered me
a draw
and normally i would accept a draw but
it was a team competition and
i saw that i'm not risking so much
and i could always make make a draw
later on and so i decided to
to play on i i went um
rk6 here with the idea to
to activate the the rook over here
rook b6 rook b4 which
seemed interesting
white goes uh bishop d1 now
in order to parry this i mean after
[Music]
uh rook b6
then just bishop c5 rook c5 and bishop
a4
roxy for bishop b3
with an equal position
so i had to i had to continue with my
uh with my plan and i went uh
rook a8 here
and again i want to go to b6 group b4
it goes uh g3 just
this is a useful move
rook b6 finally
and now this was an important moment
because he played the a3 which which is
a weakness
during the game i saw the the correct
continuation so roxy 2 was
better in order to to prepare f4 and
e5 actually he cannot do it immediately
because of knight e4 and the rook is
hanging here
although my own rook is hanging on b6
so roxy 2 was good
and now if i go to b4 um he could just
repeat the moves like
bishop d2 rock has to go back and uh
[Music]
bishop is three and uh well i cannot go
a3 here because it's just lost after b4
is this pin and he will be able to
to defend his rook on b1 after c1 let's
say and then
take my knight
so he he played a3
just he wanted to to avoid this rook
before but it was better to defend it by
by rook c2 so i went
rook c6 and now if
he if he just waits like bishop e2 i can
go
knight b3 uh rook d1 rook c8 with uh
with pressure on my ideas to go b6
knight a
uh sorry not so for knight a5 and uh
then target the c4 pawn
[Music]
but in the game he just uh
he just took on c5
and he was hoping to have good drawing
chances because of the opposite colored
bishops
so rook takes c5 the best
if i take with the pawn then just f4
followed by
e e5 it's it's about equal
so i have to to keep the structure like
this
and now attack the c4 point
he goes bishop e2 and now again
i i went back to my to my plan
and i go rook a6 with idea rook b6
to put pressure on the b to pawn which
is fixed there
well what what
should white do here i mean white is on
the defensive
and in the game he played h4 a useful
move just to gain some space on the
king side but actually probably it was
better to go b
forward well it's not easy to decide
about
upon such a move then pawn takes rook
takes
and rook a7 and followed by rook
rook a5 and it's still uh
it's still pressure
however in the game he played the
h4
now of course i continued my plan i mean
this is what you have to do in the
ending just make a plan and
stick to it rook b6
king g2
and here i was tempted to play this
bishop c3
here he he gave up upon if he goes
rook c2 then i can play bishop d4
and then followed by e5 and
this looks very strong but actually
and it probably is but actually i didn't
manage to find a winning plan for black
however in the game he decided to not to
allow me to put the bishop to d4 he
played look
d1
and then i i i grabbed the pawn so ruby
2
rook takes bishop takes rook b1
i took on a3 finally now he
he definitely has to get rid of the a4
pawns so
yeah bishop f a3 yeah rook a1
bishop b2 rook takes a4
no there was no no point to take on b7
because then the a4 pawn is uh
winning immediately the game for example
something like this
um i don't know maybe rook rook a5
followed by bishop here h3
a2 it's a win
so this was the only way to
to take the a4 pawn now i played bishop
d4
he goes f4 of course he wants to
activate his bishop
and now it was an important moment i
think i played
right here so i went e5 to change the
finally changed the double pawns
he played rook e8 i think this was
slightly worse maybe it was better to go
h5 and try to
try to exchange some pawns there as we
all know
the defending side should try to
exchange pawns
however he had this idea to go to kj
i took on f4 and here
here it was an important moment that i
want to mention it
i played the
i was not so accurate i played the rook
c6 trying to play rook b6 and activate
the queen
the the rook
but i had a better not not e5 i had a
better move here
i um i could have played
with the same idea b6 and rook a5 and uh
it turns out that if i exchange the
rooks there
it's just winning and otherwise i ha i
defend my b6 pawn and i can activate my
rook very easily so here
he just goes okay five
rook b8 uh the
uh this ending is is just lost here
yes pawn up and passport is just lost
and here my rook is suddenly very active
and this this is winning
however in the game i played rook c6 so
i had this uh i wasn't sure about that
ending or maybe i missed something
i don't know it happened 12 years ago
so rk5 he played well
and now again now i had to go e5 it was
uh
it was very strong but i played b6
instead
rook d5 and again the last moment it was
to play e5
and secure that bishop in the center
bishop f6 here i was i was a bit
imprecise
h5 in order to to exchange some pawns
e5 he took
and here he was down to
[Music]
down two seconds on the clock
and he took the took a wrong decision
he he took only five he wanted to
exchange pawns as i said
as a rule it's good to exchange pawns in
the ending
but there were better modes like king g3
in order to activate the king when i
take here just
go there it's still better for me but
white is very active
or even f5 was
was very strong
and here here it's uh it should be a
draw
so also the f5 pawn can be strong
and
white is a white is very active
however he played he took on e5
bishop uh
bishop takes e5
and here he still had a chance to play
king f3
um king f6 hello there
king is 3 and the position is
slightly better for me but
like this it doesn't allow my bishop to
to c5
but uh he played rook b5 again this was
uh
a bit imprecise but i have to say it's
uh
quite difficult to play this descending
with white
with the white pieces uh the whole point
is if i manage to bring the bishop to
c5 here and then unlock my
my rook and
i played king f6 which is good first to
activate my king
this is too early because of rook d5
with e5
so i went king f6
rook b3 king g5
activating the the king all along
king f3 bishop d4 now it's finally time
to activate this bishop
and uh the rook final drug because uh
it was stuck there for for too long
king g2 and now now i played rook c7
as you as you can notice i can bring the
bishop to c5 it's
if necessary and then
the rook is coming
a decisive effect
rook d3
and bishop bishop c5 was
was very good rock g3
check king f7 bishop d3
here he had an idea to play e5 and
take my phone
but i paired this with rook g7
apparently the rook is not so active
there but
it will help me
[Music]
push my pawn and the king can sorry
king can go over here you played king f3
bishop d4 and now the bishop returns to
e5 uh once the
basic spawn is not attacked anymore
rook g2 well
the game ended uh quite
quickly now uh bishop e5 i'm from
romania
uh king g4 rook a7
so yeah now the the game is over for
for white because the the rook is coming
in to play with the
decisive effect and as you may notice i
didn't
weaken my position here yet with g5 so
there is no way for y2 to do anything
rook f2 king g7 bishop f1
rook a1 bishop g2
well he can't he can't really defend
here bishop f1
uh rookie one so as you can see i can
attack his pawns
and uh the g5 pawn is going to decide
the game
bishop d3 he is defending them both
okay here i um i repeat it the most a
little a bit
rook g1 king f3 rook g3 k2 now i cleared
the path for the g pawn and the japan is
ready to
is ready to run i played g5 maybe
bishop d4 was uh followed by g5 was
was even more precise but this was this
was good enough
so
yes i'm i'm from romania grandmaster
from romania
rook f3 he played uh
a rook g4 of course is not my intention
to
uh to swap the rooks
bishop c2 but now you see
he he didn't manage to attack my pawns
anymore so my pawns are
safely protected by this bishop and his
bishop is uh
very bad just
trying to defend the pawns
and uh my g pawn is soon enough
going to be very strong like pushing to
g4 g3
queening and uh
this setup bishop bishop rook versus
bishop brooke with the opposite colored
bishop is very strong so
rook h4 rugby three check
king d3 and here i suck the b6
pawn because the g
pawn is already deciding i had to
calculate but i
i calculated this until the end
well uh that plant with the bishop to d5
doesn't really help
because it doesn't stop the g pawn so
it it wouldn't stop the g pawn actually
so rook b6 g3
rook b1 and here
there are many ways to win but uh what i
play what
the most precise rook f2 rook g1
and finally g2 followed by bishop
bishop h2 and white resigned since
after for example king speed uh
the bishop is falling
okay so these were the games for today i
hope
they were entertaining
and instructive although they
they contained
[Music]
some mistakes some of them more mistakes
some of them less
this uh this is
all for this evening
thank you for watching see you next time
bye bye